thanks jillian another way you can use
your pantry items is to create a spooky
treat like some halloween graveyard
pudding chef jeff jackson with the
smith's food and drug the sponsors of
this next segment shows us more
hello everybody i'm chef jeffrey smith
it's halloween i love this time of year
i get to play with my food and do lots
of spooky things have you ever heard of
dirt pudding before so we're gonna make
graveyard pudding just based off that
same idea of a chocolate pudding with
oreo sand but we're gonna have fun with
it so let's get to our pudding first so
what we're going to do is put some
powdered sugar and cocoa powder in a
bowl here and i'm just going to quick
mix it up no i'm not even going to turn
this on i just want to mix it up just a
little bit okay next is going to go in
our jello instant jello pudding
it's chocolate flavored of course and
then milk
and then some salt and then i'm just
going to turn on my mixer and then just
mix that until it comes together really
quickly
okay once that comes together like so
when it's mixed together then i'm gonna
add some vanilla
and then some heavy cream this time and
then i'm gonna stir make sure your milk
and your cream are cold by the way when
you're adding them then i'm gonna mix
this until it turns into the pudding the
final pudding that we want
okay and by the magic of television it's
done so it's nice and thick the color's
light
put this aside over here
okay now i'm gonna start having some fun
here so we're gonna just get a 9 by 13
cake dish here and we're going to put
our chocolate pudding in there
and then we're gonna decorate it and
we're gonna have some fun turn into a
graveyard there's a couple tricks that
i'm gonna share with you to kind of have
some fun with that
okay so there's our base so what we're
gonna do now is gonna put our dirt in
there of course this is just oreo
cookies or chocolate sandwich cookies
that i put in a blender blitzed them up
and then i just have this wonderful dirt
here
and then next i'm gonna put on some
grass and what i did for that is i just
took some coconut
and then put some green food coloring in
it and just mixed it up with my hands
and you get this cool grass
so we'll put our grass on there
then we're going to make it a graveyard
now and of course with a graveyard you
need to have tombstones right so what i
did is i went to a craft store and i
found these cool little edible
tombstones you could use those if you
wanted to
or you can make them by yourself so i
got some cookie dough some
sugar cookie dough
just the tube stuff and but make sure to
bake them first and then cut them into
the tombstone shape or else they won't
work so we'll do that i also found some
of course gummy worms right gotta have
gum worms
going in and out of there
and then i have some ghosts what's a
graveyard without ghosts and some
spiders
anyways you get the point right just
have fun with this stuff kids get
involved and of course they're gonna
want to eat it too
we'll put one more tombstone in there
one more spider
and that is our
lovely graveyard that dirt pudding
awesome
you can put this back in the fridge if
you wanted to or you could just serve it
right away if you're not going to serve
right away definitely put it in the
fridge and then it will kind of set up
for you and look nice and everything so
but anyways the point is to have fun
with your food at halloween you can find
all of these ingredients at your local
smiths thank you so much for watching
thank you for shopping we'll see you all
next time bye everybody thank you to
smith's food and drug for sponsoring
this segment for the full recipe
ingredients and more visit
smithsfoodanddrug.com